how did you uh prepare for this event we
know it's a very prestigious event what
was your training routine coming into
this event I've been actually very busy
this summer I've taught a couple of
summer camps and
um overall just you know spending time
with family but I've tried my best to
still do some trust work and play some
training games and things like that and
hopefully hopefully my training shows at
the right moment during the tournament
I've played a few tournaments before
this to like kind of get back into
in-person chess so well I'm trying to be
physically and also mentally fit fit so
not only
um like solving puzzles reviewing
openings but also just exercising and
relaxing so that I'm ready for long
tournament that's ahead
um before this event I played in the
World open and right before that was
Philadelphia International both in
Philadelphia
um so I didn't really have that much
time to prepare so basically as soon as
I got the invitation I started like
researching my opponents and like trying
to see what openings they played um I've
just been looking at some of my
opponents games trying to figure out
sort of how they play what their style
is what their openings are that kind of
thing I played two torments before this
they didn't go that well
um so I'm just not thinking specifically
about preparing just sort of Assortment
I mean when the field when the parents
come out I'm obviously gonna prepare as
much as it can but I just really want to
try to play the best chance I can just
the usual preparing making sure that I
am ready to start my games
it's been a little erratic
because I had College this whole year
except for one tournament that I've
played but it did not go well I mean
I've just been playing games and
checking what my opponent flight my
opponent's place and stuff well I mostly
just worked on reviewing my openings
I've looked a bit at the Players but not
too much since we don't know the Colors
oh what order I'm playing the player
until tonight
[Music]
foreign
[Music]